[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hey, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
I am [INAUDIBLE].
I work on Google Translate.
Today, we have a very special
guest, Dr. Douglas Fields.
He is a neuroscientist and
an international authority
on brain development,
neuron and glia
interactions, and the
cellular mechanisms of memory.
He is currently Chief of
Nervous System Development
and Plasticity Section at the
National Institutes of Health,
and he is the author of many
magazine articles and books,
including "Why We Snap,"
which you can grab in the back
if you haven't yet.
And later, we're going to
have a quick book signing.
And his other book
is, "The Other Brain."
Please give a warm welcome
to Dr. Douglas Fields.
[APPLAUSE]
DOUGLAS FIELDS:
Thank you very much.
Thank you all for coming.
It's a delight to be here.
So I've been given
the rare opportunity
to talk about two
books in one hour.
Normally, either one
of these subjects
would take a whole
hour, so I apologize--
I'm going to go really quick.
And I'm going to only be
able to hit the high points.
But you know, s I
realize here at Google
your CPUs are overclocked,
and you'll be able to do this.
But we'll get through it.
And the first talk is related
to the subject of snapping.
So this is a very
interesting topic
that I think touches everyone
in one way or another.
Many people won't
admit it, but everyone
admits they know somebody
else who has issues.
And snapping is
bewildering, because it's
this unconscious aggressive
impulse triggered by something
in the environment.
And it's not conscious.
It's not deliberate.
Why break a dish?
Why smash a tennis racket?
Why get into vehicular
jousting on the freeway
and wreck your car or worse?
It doesn't make any sense.
So that's what snapping is.
And that's what's
disturbing about it
is that it's not conscious.
It's rapid, triggered by
something in the environment,
and the behavior is incorrect.
It's followed by regret, so
it's kind of embarrassing.
If it's appropriate
behavior, we call it--
we don't call snapping.
We call it quick thinking
or something like that.
So it is interesting
because this
covers an unconscious
part of the brain
that we're talking about.
And it seemed to me that
this is a new subject
but a very important
and overlooked subject.
When I read the
newspapers every day,
we read about the violence
and domestic disputes,
barroom brawls, all
these kinds of things.
And it's not
mentally ill people.
People with mental illness
do not commit violent acts
any more than anyone else.
And so we do
understand how drugs
can interfere with judgment.
But I think we're
overlooking the big issue.
The majority of what we
call snapping or violence
that we read about every day
is so-called normal people.
And I'd like to
understand how that works.
But it's actually
broader than snapping.
When you get into the subject,
the book has more than that.
Because it's talking about--
it involves the neural circuitry
of unconscious behaviors
and threat detection.
What's different about
this approach in the book
is it's not a
psychological approach
that you may be familiar with.
It's a neuroscience
approach, which we
look at snapping as a behavior.
All behaviors are
controlled by the brain.
Let's go in the
brain and see what
circuits mediate this behavior.
It's only been possible with
new methods of neuroscience.
So that's the new approach--
and also, unconscious operation
of the brain, but also
fear and whatnot.
So the point is we're
all wired for violence.
We don't have to
be taught violence.
All animals need to have this
aggressive behavior in order
to protect themselves, to
protect their offspring.
Carnivores need to have
aggressive behavior in order
to capture food.
The circuits that
carry this out are not
in the conscious
part of the brain.
They're in the unconscious
part of the brain called
the hypothalamus
and other circuitry.
And that's what I'd
like to talk about is
the circuitry of snapping
and aggressive behavior.
We're all wired for
violence, and in order
to give you an idea of
what made me realize that,
I want to read a
snippet out of my book.
Because this is what inspired
me to try to understand.
It was an instance
where I snapped,
and I wanted to realize
if I could risk my life
or limb in an
instant in response
to something in
my environment, I
wanted to know how
that worked and not
be consciously aware of it.
So "After Paris, we traveled to
Barcelona for my next lecture
at an international
meeting of neuroscientists.
The morning before
the meeting began,
we made a quick visit
to the Gaudi cathedral.
Ascending the steps out of the
dingy subway station smelling
of concrete, dust,
and sweat, we emerged
in the brilliant Barcelona sun.
A crowd of passengers pressed
upon us in a gray blur."
So I was traveling to
a neuroscience meeting,
and I brought my 17-year-old
daughter with me.
That's very unusual.
Usually, I travel alone.
So we thought we'd go
see the Gaudi cathedral
before I gave my lecture.
So we're coming up out
of the subway system.
"Suddenly, I felt a
sharp tug at my pant leg.
As if swatting a mosquito, I
slapped the zippered pocket
above my left knee.
My wallet was gone.
My left arm shot back
blindly in a flash.
I clotheslined the
robber as he pivoted
to hand my wallet
off to his partner
and flee down the steps.
As if swinging a sledgehammer,
I hurled him by his neck
over my left hip and slammed him
belly-first onto the pavement,
where I flattened him to the
ground and applied a headlock.
Splaying my legs for hip
control like a wrestler pinning
an opponent, I yelled for help.
All right, 56-years-old, 130
pounds, wire-rimmed glasses,
gray hair.
I have no martial arts training.
[LAUGHS] I have no
military experience,
no background in
street fighting.
Drawing on junior high school
wrestling moves 40 years ago,
I found myself applying
an illegal chokehold.
The street-smart hoodlum
struggling in my arms
was in his late
20s or early 30s.
'Police!' I shouted.
'Call the police.
I've got him.'
Well, there was no
reply, no gasps of shock
from the dense crowd.
No one was coming to my aid.
Instead, from my
perspective on the ground,
all I saw were mens'
feet closing in around me
in a tight circle.
They were all part of the gang.
Oblivious to being
hunted as prey,
we assumed that the crowd was
the normal throng of passengers
bumping and jostling through
the Barcelona metro system.
The muscled beneath me
struggled to break my grip.
With his neck in the
crook of my left arm,
I cinched with all the
force my biceps could
produce, cutting the
blood off to his brain
and air to his lungs.
Bending his head back, I torqued
his spine backward painfully,
tipping his face skyward,
his eyes and mouth
open wide in shock,
pain, and fear.
The wallet popped free as he
tossed it toward his accomplice
and grass furiously at my
arm to break my strength.
'That's my wallet,' I yelled.
A woman's hand shot between
the thick of the legs.
Instantly, I recognized
it as my daughter's.
She had been cut off by
the gang that encircled
and trapped us, encircling me
silently like a pack of wolves.
Captain of the ultimate
Frisbee team, Kelly
dove through the
air in an arc as
if to deflect the disk
inches from an opponent's
grasp in a full on layout
on the solid concrete.
She intercepted
the pass in mid-air
and tipped the wallet into the
palm of my outstretched right
hand.
Reading the eyes of
an accomplice fixating
on my BlackBerry
spinning on the pavement,
she lunged again and
beat him to the prize.
With my wallet retrieved,
I realized then
I was horribly outnumbered.
I released the thief and
bounced to the balls of my feet
as he scurried
backwards on his butt,
like an injured crab escaping.
'Crazy man,' he gasped.
Looking into the eyes of the
half dozen muscular thugs
surrounding me, I
tried to discern
if he choked out those parting
words to deflect suspicion
or if he meant it as a threat.
Now what?
A massive surge of adrenaline
fueled my twitching muscles
and nerves to levels of raw
power I'd never felt before.
I was now struggling not to pick
up the next hoodlum squaring
off with me, hoist
him over my head,
and hurl him into
the accomplices,
knocking them all down
the steps of the metro
station like bowling pins.
Now, it wasn't a question
of whether I could
execute the superhuman feat.
I had no doubt
that I could do it.
I was charged with adrenaline.
Rather, I was trying
not to do it simply
because this might not be my
best move, at least not yet.
Suddenly, a middle-aged
well-dressed Spaniard
stuck casually between
me and the attackers
and with flicking shooing
motions of his fingers,
he said, 'He no crazy.
Go now.' Without
breaking stride,
he descended the steps
into the metro station.
As he passed me, he
smiled and said, 'Bueno.
Good.
Go now.' In passing, he had
deflected the situation to its
best possible outcome, a draw.
The band of robbers scattered
into the metro station
like rats down a sewer,
leaving my daughter
and me standing there
stunned, my wallet
clenched in a death
grip in my right hand.
Unfortunately, that
was not the end of it.
The gang pursued Kelly
and me throughout the city
for the next two hours.
They were not after
my wallet anymore.
I had humiliated and beaten
up a member of their gang.
They wanted revenge.
I tried every trick
to elude them--
fleeing into tourist shops
and through noisy restaurants,
cutting through back alleys,
abruptly crossing streets
to reverse course, changing
clothing, and when they got too
close, leaving the
sidewalk and running down
the center of the boulevard,
weaving through oncoming cars.
At one point, we
stopped traffic to jump
into a taxi in the middle
of a three-lane boulevard,
but they had cell phones.
And everywhere we went,
they sent increasingly
menacing tattooed thugs
with steroid-bloated biceps
to intercept us.
As we dodged the
gang of robbers,
we witnessed them casually pick
wallets from two more tourists.
I even snapped photographs
of them doing it.
A stupid mistake,
as it turned out,
because the lookout on
my side of the street
caught me doing it.
The unshaven goon
came running up
the sidewalk jabbering
Russian into a cell phone
and extending a video camera
in an unconvincing attempt
to pass as a tourist.
We fled down the side street.
As they closed in on us, we
were forced to jump into a taxi
and escape to a small
town an hour away.
In the cab, my daughter
asked in a tone
filled with shock and
disbelief, 'Where did you
learn to do that?
I looked over and saw you
swinging some guy around
by the neck.
I couldn't figure out
what was happening.'
I laughed a nervous relief.
170 euro cab fare later,
we were broke but safe.
And now my daughter is convinced
that my job at the National
Institutes of Health
is just a cover
for my real job as a spy."
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so I realized--
there I was on the ground.
And suddenly this
thought bubbles up
to my head, what the
heck are you doing?
So the point is the
neural circuitry
involved in that behavior didn't
involve my cerebral cortex.
And that's because
when you're faced
with a sudden
threatening situation,
conscious deliberation
is too slow.
Your conscious brain can't
hold enough information,
and it operates too slowly.
So the brain's threat
detection mechanism
is subcortical, unconscious,
and the wiring for this
is in the amygdala and
in the hypothalamus.
So as I was wandering
around Barcelona
with my daughter
consciously engaged
in where we're going to go,
my threat detection mechanism
was looking at
threats, and that's
happening with all of you.
You're constantly--
huge part of your brain
devoted to threat detection
and on the lookout for threats.
So all the sensory
information, before it
goes to your cerebral
cortex, vision,
sound goes to the center of
your threat detection mechanism
in the amygdala.
That's why you can dodge a
basketball, get out of the way,
and then you go, what was that?
That was visual information
going to your amygdala
and then later goes to
your cerebral cortex,
but you've already acted.
So in the early
'20s, Walter Hess
stuck electrodes
into a cat brain
and stimulated different
parts of the brain.
And he found one part
in the hypothalamus.
When he stimulated this, the
cat launched into an attack
and would kill another
animal in its cage.
So this area is called the
hypothalamic attack area.
And this is true
in other animals,
and humans have it as well.
So the question is, what
feeds into this attack area
to cause this violent response?
And the new
information is showing
that very discreet circuits
feed into this area in response
to different threats.
Aggressive behavior
is highly regulated.
You're not going to engage
in aggression for anything
but very-- except
very specific reasons,
because you're risking
your life and limb.
So it's highly regulated.
Now, although it seems that
anything can trigger aggression
when you read the
paper, in fact,
very few things can, only
nine different things.
And these involve
different circuits.
So what scientists have been
able to do in recent years
is use new methods, optogenetics
and genetic engineering,
so you can engineer neurons
to release flashes of light
when they fire,
stick a fiber optic
camera into an
experimental animal,
have it engage in aggression,
and see which neurons light up.
And now, you know the circuitry.
You can activate and
inactivate specific neurons
by shining a laser into
the brain, and neurons that
are genetically encoded to
respond to that light by firing
or inhibiting-- so
now, you can turn it
on behaviors, different
aggressive behaviors.
What this line of
research has shown
is that very specific behaviors,
like maternal aggression--
you're familiar--
we're all familiar
with maternal aggression.
If you threaten
a mother's young,
then the mother will attack.
Using these methods
I've talked about,
you could see that circuitry.
You can activate those
circuits with a laser
and activate the mother to
exhibit aggressive behavior
against an intruder.
You can inactivate that, and
the mother will no longer
protect her pups.
However, she still will
have aggressive responses
to different kinds of threats.
So this has led to realizing
that our threat detection
mechanism, unlike the old
idea of the lizard brain--
a primitive part
the brain causes
you to do beastly things--
no, we have very elaborate,
exquisite neural circuitry to
release aggression in response
to specific triggers.
So let me tell you
about the triggers.
And again, these are
based on neural circuitry,
not on some classification.
And if you read the neuroscience
behaviorist, physiologist,
and psychologist, they all
have different terminology
for aggression-- different
kinds of aggression.
I've dispensed with that
and for two reasons.
I thought that would be helpful
to understand the mechanisms
to having a mnemonic, so you
can remember these nine circuits
that will trigger aggression.
And secondly, this
will also allow
you to control the circuitry,
because in fact, we
have these circuits
because we need them.
You don't want to
prevent this response
in the right
circumstance; you just
want to prevent the misfires.
So if you can suddenly feel the
sense of rage on the highway,
let's say, and understand
which of these LIFEMORTS
it triggered--
the mnemonic I created
was LIFEMORTS--
then you can control
the rage response.
Because you'll realize
it's a misfire,
and the rage will subside.
So there's not really time to
go through all these triggers,
but I'll just quickly
talk about some.
L for Life and Limb.
We've already talked about
defensive aggression.
If you're attacked,
you will fight back.
Any animal will.
We also mentioned
maternal aggression.
That's the F in LIFEMORTS.
The E trigger is Environment.
Many animals are
territorial, and they
will defend their territory
aggressively and mark it.
They'll fiercely
defend intruders.
Primates and humans are
fiercely territorial.
Intruders will be shot.
If somebody enters
your house unannounced,
it's going to trigger
an aggressive response.
So that's the E trigger.
Just going to give
you another example.
I can't go through them all.
T Is for Tribe.
Social animals use aggression
to protect their group.
Many animals will have this,
and certainly human beings
have this capability as well.
I mean, the selective
service system
proves that we all
have the capability
for violence and
destruction to protect
our country, for example.
So that's the T for Tribe.
[INAUDIBLE]
We need to realize that's
also the key to our success,
that we can go shirts
and skins and play
at the maximal physical, mental
capability of a human being
on a basketball court,
just arbitrarily
divided into two teams.
This is what got us to the moon.
We compete with another country.
So this is really the key
to our success as a species,
but it also leads to racism.
It leads to wars.
It leads to gang violence.
So those are two of the
triggers that I want to mention.
And I just don't have time
to go through them all,
but I want to give one--
make one more point.
We have these circuits
embedded in our brain
because we have the same
brain we had 100,000 years ago
when we lived in the
plains of Africa,
and we were fighting tooth
and nail for survival.
Same brain, but
we're now operating
in an environment our brain has
never evolved to operate in--
completely different world.
So what happens is
you get misfires
triggered by situations
in the modern world that
never existed.
Driving is a great example.
It hits almost all
these triggers.
So I'll just give you one,
and it's that e trigger.
So you're out on 101.
You're driving on the freeway.
Somebody cuts in front of you.
Suddenly, you're
feeling enraged,
and some people will end
in a gun battle or a wreck.
But many people will feel sudden
rage when somebody does that.
Why?
Why do we feel anger?
Why don't we feel
some other emotion?
That's a misfire.
We perceive the area around
our cars our territory.
Somebody's intruded into our
territory, tripped this trigger
for us to defend it.
For the purpose of the
activity we're involved in,
transportation,
it doesn't matter
if the guy's on your front
bumper or your back bumper.
It's a matter of a couple
of seconds difference.
But it's this illusion that
we're traveling with territory.
If you're running and having
a foot race over the ground,
that never happens.
People are free to
run ahead of you.
Somebody cuts in front of you
and is faster, you might laugh.
You wouldn't get angry.
So that's an example
of a misfire.
So the point is we have these
circuits because we need them.
They exist because they're
important to our survival.
And it's not necessarily a
disorder but a misfiring.
And I want to give an example--
again, read a snippet out
of the book that demonstrates
why we have these triggers
and just say that in many
cases, the same thing happens
when you have a hero.
We'll come to the
aid of somebody
and they say, well, what were
you thinking when you did that?
And they'll say, I didn't think.
I just reacted.
And afterwards, they're shaking.
But they were heroic.
So here's a snippet
from the book.
"'Lucky, what are you doing?
Get your butt up here.
Let's go.' Heather Lucky
Penny was a 26-year-old DC Air
National Guard lieutenant
stationed in Andrews Air Force
Base in Maryland.
Jolted by urgency, she aborted
the methodical checklist,
climbed in, ignited the engines,
and screamed for a ground crew
to pull the wheel chocks.
Within minutes,
the petite blonde
was piloting the F-16 fighter
jets screeching at top speed
through the crystal blue sky
with her commander, Colonel
Marc Sasseville, piloting
his own jet on her wing.
The date was September 11, 2001.
Both the twin towers and the
Pentagon had just been hit.
There was a fourth
passenger jet commandeered
by Islamic terrorists
targeting the United States
capital and the White House.
Obviously, Heather knew
there was no chance
that any of the men,
women, and children
onboard United
Airlines 757 passenger
jet she was intent on
intercepting setting
would survive.
In an improbable twist of
fate, there was a good chance
that Heather Penny's
own father could
be the captain on
United Flight 93, which
she was determined to destroy.
'This sounds cold-hearted.
I mean, that was my Daddy,"
Penny said in an interview
afterwards.
'I couldn't think about it.
I had a job to do,' she
said later to her mom.
'We don't train to bring down
airliners,' Colonel Sasseville
said, describing
the gut wrenching,
unthinkable act he and Heather
Penny were about to commit.
Training would have been
useless in any case.
Neither of their jets was armed.
No one had anticipated the need
to have fully-armed fighter
jets at the ready to protect
against an aerial attack
originating from within
the United States.
'I'm going to go for the
cockpit,' Sasseville said.
'I'll take the tail,' Penny
replied without hesitation.
'I genuinely believed that this
was going to be the last time I
took off,' she said, now a
single mom with two girls.
'I had already given myself
up knowing what my duty was.'
She was fully
committed to ramming
her jet into the passenger
plane to bring it down.
As fate would have it, her
father, Colonel John Penny,
was not piloting
United 93 that morning.
It was his good
friend Jason Dahl.
With Jason on the
plane, it would
have been an additional level
of grief John Penny said later.
But Lieutenant Penny
and Colonel Sasseville
never had to execute
their kamikaze mission.
'Let's roll,' said
32-year-old Todd Beamer,
a passenger on a
hijacked flight.
Those were the last words of
the soon-to-be father ending
his conversation with telephone
switchboard operator Lisa
Jefferson whom he had
been relaying information
to for the last 13
minutes of the hijacking.
They had just finished reciting
the Lord's Prayer and Psalms 23
together.
'Though I walk through the
valley of the shadow of death,
I fear no evil, for
thou art with me,
they rod and they staff.
They comfort me.'
Beamer and the other passengers
stormed the hijackers.
Jeremy Glick was a
six-foot judo champion.
Mark Bingham was a rugby player.
Tom Burnett had been
a college quarterback.
Lewis [? Nakh ?]
was a weightlifter.
William Cashman, a
former paratrooper.
The cockpit recorder captures
the sound of food carts ramming
the cockpit door and
the cries of terrorists
screaming at one another
to hold the door closed.
The door burst open.
'Let's get him,' is heard on
the recording as passengers
overwhelm the terrorists.
'They were the true
heroes,' Heather Penny says.
'There were average,
everyday Americans
who gave their lives
to save countless more.
Their selflessness reminds us
that we are a part of something
greater than ourselves, that
there are things in this world
more important than ourselves.'
Today, there's a memorial
on the green pastures
in southwestern Pennsylvania,
and the White House
and the United
States capital stands
spared from the destruction.
This is the power
of the tribe trigger
to life-risking violence.
Gangs, wars, racism
are its ugly dark side.
But this bit of neural
circuitry is very much
a part of what makes us human.
It can unleash the
best in human nature,
selfless sacrifice for others.
It is the trigger of heroism.
And as the monument now standing
in the fields of Pennsylvania
remind us, it's a vital
part of every one of us."
So we have these
circuits for a reason.
In the interest of time,
I have to come to a close.
I've got other
important points that I
would like to make-- is
that stress is important.
Knowing the circuits
is important,
because you can control it.
Understanding that stress
changes that threshold--
if you're in a
stressful environment,
you're more likely
to have these trip,
same as the military
putting its defense
mechanism on high alert.
If you grow up in bad part
of Palo Alto or Baltimore,
you're going to wire
the brain so that you
have a hair-trigger, because you
can't afford to be victimized.
And I don't want to give away
the book, but-- well, I will.
I reacted that way in
Barcelona because we
were under intense stress.
That was the second
time we were robbed.
And my amygdala had
learned that and didn't
talk to my cortex
about it, but it
wasn't going to happen again.
The second point
I'd like to make
is that this mechanism--
threat detection
mechanism is controlled
by the cerebral cortex.
And there are people who
are completely nonviolent,
and I interviewed them--
James, for example, who will
kill nothing and no living
animal.
And so it is possible
to have cortical control
over the circuitry.
I spoke to a SEAL Team
Six member, told him
what I did in Barcelona.
He said, yeah, I never
would have done that.
Here's a guy who could take
out a pickpocket with a judo
chop while doing a selfie,
and he wouldn't have done it.
And they train so that they can
control, with cortical control,
these defensive behaviors.
And the other thing I wish I had
time to talk about is gender.
The most important factor
in aggression is gender.
94% of all criminals in prison
for violent crime are male,
but 94% of the people who have
been given awards for heroism
by the Carnegie
Foundation are male.
A quarter of those died,
instantly giving their life,
often a stranger, to
come to their aid.
So gender is very important.
The neuroscience of that
is very interesting.
Men and women face
different threats.
They're threat detection
wiring is different.
I wish I could go into that.
Let's see.
I'll just end on one thing, that
it has been known for some time
that stimulating the
hypothalamic attack
region in animals, in addition
to inducing aggression,
can induce copulation.
So you know through
literature and psychology,
there's always this connection
between sex and violence.
Now what we never knew
is if you stimulate
this hypothalamic
region, are you
stimulating nerve
fibers that are just
passing by your
electrode, and the neurons
or somewhere else in the brain?
Well, it turns out-- recent
work by David Anderson
and his colleagues at Caltech
using the new methods,
optogenetics, that found
that they stimulate neurons
in the hypothalamic region,
and the same neurons control
copulation and aggression.
And they use a fiber optic laser
to stimulate these neurons,
and they can switch--
flip of a switch--
make this mouse go from
mating to fighting.
So that's interesting.
So in conclusion, I want
to say that understanding
is the first step in
controlling anything.
So I hope that people can
understand that we all
have this circuitry,
how it works,
that it's an amazingly
intricate and elaborate circuit.
I hope that people can
benefit from understanding
how it can misfire and
that we do need better ways
to control aggression,
particularly these days when
we have so much aggression.
The police are always
looking for a motive.
I understand what they say.
We're looking for a motive.
But there is no motive.
It's a rage-induced violence.
And that's what I
hope that we can
begin to understand by getting
a neuroscience perspective to go
along with the perspective
of psychology and behavior.
So that's it for why we snap.
Thank you.
Now, for something
completely different--
[APPLAUSE]
I have to go to my second talk.
I tell you, either of these
talks is over an hour.
And the Q&A is the best part,
but we just don't have time.
So let's talk about
the other brain.
Throughout my
career, I've studied
how neurons are wired
together in development,
how they change the strength
of their synaptic connections
through experience, and
how we store memories.
But did you know that only
15% of the cells in your brain
are neurons?
What are the other 85%?
Well, they're called glia.
The word means glue.
And that's how
they've been regarded
is just packing material.
Glia do not fire
electrical impulses,
so they're considered the
cellular domestic servants
of neurons.
They clean up after neurons, or
they remove neurotransmitters
and maintain the ionic balance.
They certainly respond
to injury and disease.
But in recent years,
neuroscientists
have come to realize
that these cells do
far more than anyone expected.
Excuse me, I'm trying
to stay on time.
These cells do far more
than anyone ever expected.
In fact, glia are involved in
every aspect of brain function
in health and
disease, and they're
overturning our
century-old assumption
about how the brain works.
So this is what I
call the other brain.
It's an exciting new
frontier of science
that's only now being explored.
So I want to describe to you
the major kinds of glial cells,
tell you some of
the things they do.
I'm going to have to skip
a lot of things they do--
hit the high points.
And some of this work's
from my lab, but most of it
comes from discoveries
from around the world.
And I'm speaking here today
in a personal capacity
and not representing, in an
official way, the NIH at all.
But first, let's trace back
to the roots of the story
and try to understand
how we could
have overlooked half the brain,
especially brain scientists.
So this is the object
of our fascination.
You know, all our
thoughts, our intellect,
our emotions, our compassion,
hate, reasoning, perceptions,
creativity, music,
art, everything
comes out of this bodily organ.
Our unconscious
automatic responses--
our respiration control,
temperature control,
kinds of things I was
just talking about--
threat detection,
our personality,
and our identity, our
memories, our cycles of sleep--
all of this comes from
two-and-a-half pounds of flesh
that can think.
Yet to look at it, we
don't have idea how
it does any of those things.
And the reason is that the
working parts of the brain
are so concentrated
and minute, they're
invisible to the human eye.
Yet, our fundamental idea
about how the brain works
hasn't changed in 100 years.
We're so accustomed to this
analogy of the brain working
as an electronic circuit
that it's difficult for us
to think that it might operate
in any other way, but it could.
And it's hard for us to realize
that when this electric circuit
analogy was
proposed, it was seen
as revolutionary
and controversial.
So our understanding
of how the brain works
is based on an Italian
neuroscientist, Golgi,
who developed a
staining method that
allowed us, for the first
time, to see neurons.
And you can imagine
their excitement
when they looked at
these exquisite cells
unlike anything
else in the body.
Ramon y Cajal, looking
at the same tissue,
using the same method saw
something entirely different.
Golgi saw that
neurons were connected
into a hydraulic network.
Hydraulics was the most
advanced science of the day.
That's why we probably
think of the brain working
like a computer
today, because that's
the most advanced science.
But he saw it as hydraulics.
All of these pathways
are hooked together.
But Cajal was an artist
before he was a scientist,
and he had an ability to
determine function from form.
And looking at
the same material,
he had a sudden insight
that neurons were not
connected together, that
they-- each one was separate,
and each neuron was separated
by a gulf of separation,
which he called a synapse.
And he saw logic.
That's what these arrows are.
He realized that the
neurons are polarized,
that information passes
one way through neurons,
in through the dendrites
and out through the axons.
So all of our ideas about
how the brain worked
is based on this idea,
the neuron doctrine.
And that is that communication
and information processing
in the brain takes place by
electrical signals flowing
through neurons,
communicating across synapses.
But in the last few
years, scientists
have become startled to realize
that this assumption is not
entirely correct.
Now, Cajal made these
insightful discoveries
with simple tools--
razorblades, simple microscopes.
Here he is working
in his kitchen.
So it's amazing.
You can't even see a synapse
with a light microscope.
It's smaller than you can see.
Today, we use the most
advanced electron microscopy
supercomputers.
This is from Mark Ellisman's
lab in UC San Diego.
In order to study to
understand neural structure,
here's, from his
lab, one neuron.
One neuron can have up
to 100,000 synapses.
That's what these little
spines are on these dendrites.
Your brain and spinal
cord are comprised
of 100 billion neurons, all
have to be connected, correct?
But this is not a vacuum
of outer space over here,
except in our thinking.
So let's look at what
the tissue really looks
like-- again, from
Mark Ellisman's lab.
What we're doing now
is going into the brain
of a rat at an electron
microscope level,
peeling away layer at a time.
Here's a blood vessel.
There is a nucleus.
Here are the axons going by.
The point is only 15% of what
you're seeing are neurons.
And at this magnification,
you can't even see synapses.
There's got to be enormous
communication going
on among these cells that is
non-synaptic and non-neuronal.
And look at the
intricate circuitry
we were talking about.
And I think you can appreciate
what Cajal achieved.
Now as you zoom back,
you see that this
is only a thin section
that's only six-layers thick
of this mouse brain.
So neurons are great.
They have these
elaborate cell bodies.
They form these
networks, but so do glia.
As you got the evolutionary tree
from lower animals to higher,
you get more glia per
neuron the higher you go up
on the evolutionary tree.
If you raise an animal in
an enriched environment,
you will get more glia.
The brain gets thicker.
It's because you get more glia.
And if that doesn't
interest you,
when Marian Diamond
here at UC Berkeley
looked at the brain of Albert
Einstein to try and understand
why he was so intelligent,
she couldn't find
any difference in his neurons.
But what she found
is that he had
more glia in the parts of the
brain involved in imagination.
So that's just an observation.
Doesn't prove
anything, but it really
intrigued people that glia might
be doing more than we think.
So physiologists, how did
we miss half the brain?
Well, we used the wrong
tools physiologists
use tools to study
electrical signals,
but glia don't communicate
using electricity.
So let me invite
you into my lab,
and I'll show you how
physiologists study the brain.
The first thing we do is we
dissect out the part we want.
This is the
hippocampus of a rat.
Then, we slice it very thin,
400 microns thick in this case,
so that we can keep
this tissue alive.
Then, we put this brain
slice into a Faraday cage,
because we have to exclude all
the electrical interference
in our modern environment.
We use amplifiers
and stimulators
so that we can record the
weak signals in neurons
and synapses.
Here, I'm studying
something called
LTP where the synapse gets
strengthened during a memory.
The tissue is kept alive in
artificial cerebral spinal
fluid, warmed, oxygenated.
And then, we use
these electrodes
to stimulate and record
the electrical activity.
The point is all of this is
useless, because glia don't
communicate with electricity.
So what broke it open?
What broke open the other brain
was kids playing video games.
Because playing video
games drove the development
of faster computers, color
monitors, better video cameras.
So scientists grafted
all that technology
under the microscope.
And in the past, we just used
formaldehyde, fixed the tissue,
stained it, and
looked at dead tissue.
But now with the video
camera on the microscope,
we could look at living tissue.
And new dyes were
developed that work
like this, a glow stick, where
when two compounds get mixed,
it creates light.
This led to something called
calcium imaging, where dyes
were developed that calcium--
when calcium was added, glowed.
Why was that important?
Because when neurons fire,
calcium ions come in.
So this would allow us to
put a dye in brain tissue
and watch neurons fire
electrical activity
and use a microscope instead
of using electrical recording.
And it was so exciting,
when we first did this,
to see neurons firing.
But it exposed the other brain.
The textbook view of
the neuron synapses
always leaves out this part.
It's really the part
comprised of astrocytes.
We can find out
what these cells are
doing by using calcium imaging.
And as I'll show you
here, we put a calcium
dye in with astrocytes.
Pseudocolor, so
calcium is bright red.
Watch what's happening.
These cells are
communicating, and they're not
using electricity.
They're communicating
with waves of calcium.
And watch this.
When I stimulate
the neurons here,
it'll look like lightning bolts.
There-- the
astrocytes responded.
So now, we have
non-electric communication
going through brain
cells, not neurons,
responding to
electrical activity
in neurons, no synapses-- all
outside the neuron doctrine.
Why are they doing this?
How are they doing this?
So quickly discovered
how they're doing this.
And you can participate
in the same way,
because Peter Guthrie
loaned me this image, which
was this experiment in which
they did an experiment to test.
One idea is calcium might just
go through the cell membrane
through gap junctions,
which are kinds
of channels between cells.
And that's how calcium
waves go through tissue.
So to prove that, they made
a firebreak, so they just
scratched off the
cells here in culture,
started a calcium wave here.
And if this is
the way it worked,
then the signaling should
stop at the firebreak.
So now, you can
see, the same way
they did, the first time they
did their experiment, what
happened.
Glial cells communicate
by broadcasting signals.
They don't have to be touching.
Those signals are
neurotransmitters.
Quickly, it turned out that
glial cells, astrocytes,
have the same neurotransmitter
receptors that neurons have
to communicate at synapses.
And they're releasing the
same neurotransmitters.
That means that they
can communicate,
but they can also interact
with signaling that's going
on with neurons at synapses.
So we understand that neuronal
communication by the neuron
doctrine takes place
by neurotransmitters
going from presynaptic to
the postsynaptic membrane.
Of course, there's never
anything else shown,
but let's take a
look at here at glia.
These are actual glial
cells, astrocytes.
When the neurotransmitter
is released,
it definitely signals
to the other cell,
but it's also picked
up by the astrocyte.
The astrocyte, in turn,
releases neurotransmitters
that can regulate.
It can augment or inhibit
synaptic transmission.
So astrocytes can control
the strength of the synapse.
And because they can
signal among each other
without electricity,
they can send that signal
to a different
part of the brain,
release signaling compounds
and neurotransmitters
to control a synapse in a
different part of the brain
that's not wired to
this part through
a non-electric mechanism
of communication,
through non-neurons.
That's what I call
the other brain.
And so this, I think,
is so fascinating.
Here's another picture.
I just love watching
these cells communicating.
So we're 100 years behind
understanding glia--
again from Mark Ellisman's lab.
We don't know the basic
things about their morphology.
They're really complicated.
They fill all the space
between neurons and interact
with the synapses.
And what was recently
discovered, a big surprise,
is that they form
non-overlapping domains.
So they divide up the cerebral
cortex into separate domains.
We don't know why, but
it seems that astrocytes
may impose a higher
level of structure
on information
processing in the brain.
You can look at a
neuron from a rat,
and it's identical to
a neuron in a human.
Not true for astrocytes.
Human astrocytes are unique.
They're even different
from primate astrocytes.
They're huge.
One human astrocyte can
encompass two million synapses.
And an interesting experiment
by Nedergaard and Goldman,
they transplanted human
astrocytes into mice,
and it made these
mice brilliant.
They ran mazes
quicker, and synapses
strengthened much easier.
Moving on to other
things astrocytes
do-- astrocytes are
associated with blood vessels.
I told you they take
neurotransmitters.
They dump the waste from
synapses and neurons
into the bloodstream.
They also take nutrients
out of the bloodstream
and deliver them to the neurons.
Look this intricate structure.
If you could see, they're
interacting with synapses.
But this also involves
astrocytes and all kinds
of vascular disorders.
Astrocytes also
control blood flow.
This is from Eric Newman's lab.
Here is a blood
vessel in the retina.
Here's an astrocyte.
And he's stimulated the neurons
to fire by shining a light.
You'll see that here
with the yellow dot.
And look what happens
to the blood vessel.
Astrocytes control the local
swelling and constriction
of blood vessels in the
brain, so in response
to neural activity.
You may be familiar
with fMRI, which is used
to image activity in the brain.
That's based on
local blood flow.
It doesn't sense neural
activity directly.
It's sensing
oxygenated hemoglobin.
And the astrocytes are
controlling that local blood
flow.
Neurodegenerative
diseases overlooked glia,
and now we know they're involved
in all kinds of disorders--
ALS, Parkinson's, epilepsy.
Don't have time to go into it.
Brain cancer has almost
nothing to do with neurons,
because neurons don't divide.
And cancers run
away cell division.
But new research
developing new drugs
that can target
these brain cells
is leading to new therapies
to treat brain cancer.
And here, this one's coming
right in on the cancer better
than surgery.
This was a surprise--
astrocytes and glia involved
in psychiatric illnesses.
Schizophrenia,
bipolar, depression
are all associated with
changes in astrocytes
and the other glia.
We understand these
are all disorders
of synaptic transmission,
and we treat them
with SSRIs and other drugs to
control synaptic transmission.
But what's the cell that does
this in the brain normally?
Astrocytes.
So astrocytes could be
the cause or be involved
in a number of
psychiatric conditions,
because they stabilize
the environment.
They release neurotransmitters
and growth factors and whatnot.
And in fact, discoveries are
often made and then forgotten.
The electroshock
therapy that's used
for treating depression, still
the most effective treatment
for depression that can't
be treated in other ways,
where did that crazy idea
come from of shocking
a person's brain and curing them
of schizophrenia or depression?
Came from Ladislas
Meduna, who, in the 1930s,
was a pathologist.
And he noticed people who died
of schizophrenia and depression
had fewer astrocytes
in their brain.
And people who died of
epilepsy had too many.
So he just said,
oh, these disorders
are caused by an
imbalance of astrocytes.
So he induced a seizure to
try to make more astrocytes
and cure schizophrenia
and depression.
And now, we don't know
that that's how it works,
but considering all of the
growth factors and functions
that astrocytes carry
out, they're certainly
likely to be part of it.
And new drugs can
be treated to that.
There are four kinds of glia.
So far, I've only
talked about astrocytes.
The brain has its
own immune cell
isolated from the bloodstream
by the blood brain barrier.
And these are called microglia.
And in these experiments
by the [? Gann ?] lab,
engineered a mouse
genetically so
that the microglia
fluoresce green.
Then, he put a
window in the cranium
and stuck the mouse's
head under the microscope
and looked into the
brain and then could
see what these
microglia are doing.
In addition, he created an
injury with a laser beam,
and here's what they found.
These cells were dynamic.
They were moving.
And when you create an
injury, they were like Marines
descending on this-- it could
be a bacteria or a virus
or an injury--
to deal with this.
So this is going on in
your brain right now.
Those little fingers are going
around checking your synapses
for damage and whatnot.
Glia are involved in
infectious disease.
Good example is HIV.
Doesn't even affect neurons;
yet, there's dementia in HIV.
But it does affect astrocytes.
In Alzheimer's, ever
since Alzheimer described
the disorder, he noticed
microglia involved
and also these plaques.
Well, these amyloid plaques
are surrounded by microglia.
But we now can see that they're
eating the amyloid involved
in Alzheimer's.
And this is thought to be
just a reaction to pathology,
but now you realize,
well, what if they
don't carry out this function
normally throughout life?
That could cause Alzheimer's.
And in fact, new research are
showing that microglia becomes
senescent ahead of the neuronal
dysfunctions in the brain,
indicating a role of microglia
in initiating Alzheimer's.
Chronic pain, it also involves--
and morphine addiction
also involves microglia.
And chronic pain is a
pain that won't go away
after your injury heals.
You have an injury to
the peripheral nerve.
It turns out that the microglia
inside the spinal cord
become reactive.
They change.
They start to release
substances like cytokines
and other factors that
make neurons excitable.
So your pain neurons are
firing because the microglia
are stimulating them.
And here, you can see
microglia releasing
these vesicles full of all
of these kinds of substances
that excite neurons
and cause pain.
This is also important
in opiate addiction,
because opiates decrease
neural activity.
Turns out microglia
release substances
to bring it back to
normal, and you ratchet it
up so that you now need more
and more and more morphine.
And if you block the
morphine, then you
have this terrible rebound.
So microglia are
involved in that.
Another interesting
aspect of microglia
is that many people will take
marijuana to control pain
and inflammation.
They don't want the
cognitive side effects.
And it turns out that
the receptor that
is important in
inflammation and pain
is on microglia, not on neurons,
is called a CB2 receptor.
And this is leading to new drugs
that can treat pain and not
involve--
not have the cognitive effects.
Now, I'm going to end
with myelin-forming cells.
These cells form electrical
insulation on the axons.
We've cut an exon here
in half, nerve fiber.
And it's wrapped around
this membrane of insulation
like electrical tape.
Schwann cells, spindle-shaped
cells, do that in your arms
and trunk, the peripheral
nervous system.
And these octopus cells do this
in the central nervous system,
a very different cell.
Now, I want to show you
the experiment that got me
into neuron-glia interactions.
And this looks a little old,
because this is old technology.
But I put DRG neurons,
which are sensory neurons--
the ones that sense
pain and touch--
in culture, these big
round circles here.
And then I added Schwann cells.
I stimulated the
neurons to fire.
I used that calcium dye.
And certainly, the
neurons responded.
But then to my surprise,
the Schwann cells did.
No synapses.
And again, why is
this happening?
How does it happen?
What are the consequences?
That's what got me interested.
Then, I moved into the
central nervous system,
because oligodendrocytes
are the myelin-forming cells
in the central nervous system.
Cells unlike any
other cell in the body
can wrap up to 100 layers
of membrane around an axon
through 50 different
processes simultaneously.
Could they be involved
in cognitive function?
So myelinating glia changed the
way impulses are transmitted.
They accelerate the
speed of transmission
by constraining
impulses to be generated
only at these bare patches every
millimeter or so long the axon.
So they act like repeaters.
So vertebrates are the only
animals that have myelin,
and the conduction velocity
is 50 times faster.
Half the brain is
composed of white matter.
The gray matter is
what you hear about.
That's where the neurons
are and the dendrite,
but the white matter is
all bundles of these axons.
And by and large, people
ignored white matter,
because the interesting stuff
was going on up here, according
to the neuron doctrine.
The human brain, half of
it is white matter, more
than any other animal--
a mouse brain's only 10%--
because we have so
many connections.
We can see these here
with imaging DTI.
So I'm going to show you here
what white matter looks like.
I showed you similar
images of gray matter.
This is, again, serial
electron microscopy.
I need to make the point
that the structure of myelin
is submicroscopic.
You can't see it with
light microscopes.
You need electron microscopy.
So we go through.
This happens to the optic nerve.
Here's the capillary, axons.
When we find a node of
Ranvier, we can trace it,
put that in the computer.
This is only one-half
a micron distance.
And then, we can
reconstruct the structure
of the node of Ranvier.
This is understood
that myelin's important
in de-myelinating disorders,
like multiple sclerosis,
because if you have a conduction
block, conduction failure,
you're going to have
a functional failure.
But I wondered, could myelin
be involved in learning?
And here's the avenue--
here's what intrigued
me, that imaging
began to show that all kinds
of neurological diseases
had changes in white matter.
This is just brain imaging.
Things like dyslexia, autism,
stuttering, psychiatric
disorders associated with
changes in white matter.
These are synaptic disorders.
And differences in
cognitive ability
is associated with white
matter differences.
If you're good at
music or bad at music,
if you're good at
arithmetic or bad,
there are differences in
white matter structure.
Now, we're not talking
about dysfunction.
We're talking about
normal ranges of function.
So another important
thing to know
about white matter and myelin
is that it's not done at birth.
It takes place throughout
life and is shown here
in increasing colors of blue in
the human brain from the back
of the cortex to the front.
Prefrontal cortex
is not myelinated
until your early 20s.
That's also why the
prefrontal cortex judgment
higher-level executive
function can't really
take place until the early 20s.
That's when we get
legal responsibility.
But the question is, why?
If it was just insulation,
why wasn't it done
when you were born?
Why do we see
myeling taking place
over childhood and
adolescence where
we understand experience
sculpts and guides
the connections in the brain?
So this led to a theory
that myelin could be plastic
and involved in learning.
And I think this was
a head-scratcher,
but it'd probably be
really obvious to you
working in the internet.
And this is what we're calling
activity-dependent myelin.
Myelin's function is to regulate
production velocity, speed
impulse conduction.
We like to think
of the human brain
as the most complicated
network in the universe,
and to do any kind of
cognitive function,
you need to send information
from one relay point to another
to another in order to
carry out this function.
I don't know about
the internet, but I
know in transportation,
the most important thing is
when I get to my relay point.
If I'm flying to
San Francisco, I
need to get my connection
in Chicago simultaneously
with my connecting flight.
If I get there too
late, it doesn't work.
If I get there five hours
early, that's not optimal.
Has a lot of disadvantages.
We know that the
conduction speed
through all of these
pathways in the brain
varies from a slow walk--
pace of a slow walk to
the pace of a Ferrari.
How did all those
speeds get set?
If they're not set right,
then you'll have dysfunction.
And so it seemed to me likely
that maybe functional feedback
experience could
change the myelination
and then, therefore, promote
synchrony, spike time arrival.
So that's how myeling
could be involved.
Studies in other labs have
shown that after learning
there are changes in white
matter-- here's juggling.
But it's been done with
classroom learning, video game
learning, every kind of
learning you can think of.
But now, we're completely
uncharted waters.
And we've always been
thinking of the synapse.
But now, if we're going to
involve myelin in learning,
there's so many questions.
This has to be a not
synoptic communication
but action potentials.
How do myelinating glia
sense activity in axons?
There are no synapses.
How would it modify myeling?
Would it be important
in information
processing and learning?
And just how plastic is myeling?
People think of it as static.
So in my lab, we do our
studies of cell culture.
We have electrodes.
We put in sensory
neurons here, and we
put on myelinating
glia oligodendrocytes.
We stimulate them in
culture any way we want.
And we can study the effects of
neural activity on myelination.
We can do gene analysis
on the glial cells
and see how they respond
to electrical firing.
We can block signals-- we're
like neurotransmitters--
and understand how this
communication is taking place.
We can do calcium imaging.
Here's an oligo on
axons that are red.
And when I stimulate the
axons, the oligodendrocyte
responds no synapses,
no neuron doctrine.
And if I put it botulinum toxin,
which blocks vesicle release
and stimulates the neurons,
the oligodendrocytes
still responded.
That tells us that in
addition to vesicles
releasing neurotransmitters,
there are non-vesicular means,
like channels, that are
releasing neurotransmitters--
all kinds of mechanism
communication
activity-dependent
that we've ignored,
because we're so
focused on the synapse.
Our work has shown that
electrical activity promotes
the initiation of myelination.
This means that
electrically-active axons
are preferentially myelinated.
So as you're learning
to play the piano,
those pathways become
preferentially myelinated.
We've identified a number
of the cellular mechanisms,
the signals involved
over the years.
This is from our lab.
And other labs are
finding new signals.
The whole point is that
we're likely to find
as many mechanisms
of myelin plasticity
as there are for
synaptic plasticity.
It's just that we're
just getting started.
And most recent work
is Richardson's lab
used a mouse
genetically-modified so
that it couldn't form
new myelin and trained
it to run on this
wheel missing rungs,
and it learned more slowly.
So myelin facilitated
learning in this case.
So here's what the neuron
doctrine left out--
astrocytes, oligodendrocytes,
Schwann cells, micro glia,
and all the communication,
rich communication
going on among these cells.
All types of glia sense and
respond to neural activity.
Glia communicate with each
other and with neurons.
They regulate the
neuronal brain.
They're central to psychiatric
neurological disorders.
And myeling speeds
impulse conduction
may be very important as
a new set of mechanism
of learning to promote synchrony
and optimal flow of information
through complex networks.
And it's important that--
OK, I had some other
things, and they're
showing-- oh, there it is.
The neuron doctrine doesn't work
without glia, I don't think.
Glia work in different ways.
They broadcast signals, and
neurons communicate serially.
They communicate slowly.
Every movie I showed
you was sped up.
But if glia did the same
thing as neurons, why would
we have the?
So we have to look at glia
through a different lens.
And this offers new
possibilities for new drugs
and alternative treatments that
were directed towards glia.
And if you want to know
more, this is the book.
And what I tried to
capture in this book
was the excitement
of neuroscientists
on the cusp of a new
vision of the brain
that completely overturned
previous thinking.
And I wanted to
capture that moment.
This happens in science all
the time in every field,
and this is what's happening
right now in brain science.
So I'd like to thank you
very much for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We're going
to take some questions.
Feel free to come up to
the mice and ask questions.
Meanwhile, I'm going
to ask a question.
So if I understood
correctly, glia cells
regulate functioning of the
neuronal parts of the brain.
Like for example, when we
see activity in the fMRI,
that's sort of the
glia or astrocytes
specifically regulating
what parts get activated.
Is that correct?
DOUGLAS FIELDS: That's correct.
So the glia are sensing
neural activity,
and they're responding to it.
And they're modulating
neural activity.
also local blood flow.
So fMRI is interesting.
We take it for granted
that you can look at-- you
can put-- give someone
a cognitive task
and look in the brain and see
what part of the brain, what
circuitry is involved.
But you realize we're
doing that by looking
at blood-- local blood flow.
And astrocytes are
controlling that.
But that raises the
bigger question,
what if that didn't happen?
So right now as we're talking,
different parts of our brain
are being activated, and that
means that astrocytes are
controlling local blood flow.
If that didn't happen, what
would happen to cognition?
The neurons wouldn't
get enough glucose,
and they would build
up too much potassium.
So beyond this
importance in imaging,
it raises a really
fundamental question
that I think is really not
explored, is how glia and blood
flow is actually
controlling our cognition
or allowing it to take place.
SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
Are we anywhere close to
learning how to regulate glia,
so like how to regulate
the regulation,
if we wanted to do that--
DOUGLAS FIELDS: Yeah, we are.
SPEAKER: --to enhance focus and
learning and things like that?
DOUGLAS FIELDS: Exactly.
So we have to get new tools.
This is very hard.
And there are new
tools being developed.
I also have to say
part of the reason we
overlooked half the brain is
the nature of how science works.
If you worked on
unimportant cells,
you weren't likely
to get grants.
Your papers didn't get
published in big journals.
Nobody heard about it.
People's careers
were really stifled,
because they worked
on glia cells.
And now, we have that problem.
We understand the
glia are important.
But if you work on
synaptic transmission
as a neurophysiologist,
you're not
necessarily eager to have
that picture complicated,
bring in another cell, whole
other kind of technique.
And so the field is struggling
right now to make advances,
to get new techniques
that everyone will accept.
And there is this enormous--
almost a conflict of interest.
Because if you're studying
synaptic transmission,
you don't want to
understand-- you
don't want to have to
start studying myelin.
But new tools need
to be developed,
and people are working
very hard to make them.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yes, a question.
It's a very interesting talk.
About on the snap, you
said the SEALs actually
get trained not to react like--
have those snaps.
So what kind of
training they receive?
I'm very curious.
DOUGLAS FIELDS: Well,
the Navy works on these,
and he described some of the--
they have exercises to
teach them to control
these aggressive responses.
So they have very
specific programs.
One was they called the hooded--
they put a hood on them, and
then they take off the hood.
And there's all kinds
of threats around them.
There might be a hostage
situation or something.
And they have to analyze
very systematically,
what are the threats?
Prioritize them.
In other words, they rely
on cognitive function
to break down the threats
and respond not just on a gut
level.
At the same time, you'll
talk to these guys--
and I also interviewed a
lot of fascinating people--
Secret Service but
also sports figures.
They also rely on their gut.
They'll walk into a
building in Afghanistan
and say, this just
doesn't feel right.
And they'll leave and
find out that there's--
and it blows up when
they walk out the door.
And that's because your threat
detection mechanism is fast,
I told you.
That's one reason.
It's fast.
But it's also much more capable
of handling enormous amounts
of information.
We can hold eight digits
in our mind at once--
that's pathetic-- in
our consciousness.
That's why we can't
do long division.
It's not difficult, but we can't
hold that intermediate answer
long enough to do the next step.
Your unconscious
brain is constantly
crunching enormous amount of
data about your internal state,
your external state.
That's how I was able
to do that in Barcelona.
That's what amazed
me is that we all
have this ability to
constantly survey for dangers.
And so people do learn--
who work at high
levels of performance--
do learn to trust their gut and
how to develop that as well.
So it takes both.
Athletes do the same thing.
I have some stories about
athletes and avalanches
and skiers and things
where they rely on the gut.
But think about it.
The most complicated
decisions we make in life
we don't do rationally--
who to marry, where to live.
You can't make a
spreadsheet and come up--
you rely on your gut.
And that's because there's
too much information, too
many unknowns.
AUDIENCE: Our brain processes
images and experiences
differently from
the way we process
logical information in math,
computer science, for example.
And I've noticed that some
ancient orators basically
deliver a speech for hours
without looking for any note.
And also, very genius,
like at Tesla and DaVinci,
they see their invention.
For example, Tesla was able to
see the detailed picture of DC
generator before he actually
did any detailed work.
And in the past few
years, I've been
trying to kind of
combine these techniques
and try to apply that
in computer science.
For example, I-- in
[INAUDIBLE] structure,
in architecture
stuff, I try to map
that to nursery information.
Like when I walk
though nursery, I
get a lot of
inspiration, the way
they arrange the flowers
and the trees, everything.
So my question for
you is, can you
shed some light on how
our brain works in terms
of recalling experience?
For example, your
experience in Barcelona
is so vivid, where you jumped
to street and got into the taxi.
It cost you 176 euros
to evade from thugs.
It is so vivid.
So you will never
forget about that.
Versus some math formula or
some computer [INAUDIBLE]
data structure, it will be
more difficult to recall.
So how do you-- if we combine
these two parts of brain
and work together, can you
shed some light on underlying
scientific mechanisms?
Well, those are good questions.
You've combined a
couple of questions.
So first in terms of
what goes into memory,
memory is not about
recording the past.
You want to remember that great
parking place you had at Target
three years ago?
Most of what we experience
during the day, we forget.
And so what you
remember are experiences
that are likely to
have significance
for the future, survival value.
And so as you go
to sleep at night,
you relive your
experiences of the day,
and that's when short-term
memories get converted
to long-term memories.
And my lab's done
research on this as well.
And so things that are
novel are likely to be
important for the future.
If you have bad food
at a restaurant,
you don't need to do it twice.
You're not going to
do eat that again.
So emotion-- and we understand
very much about the physiology
about how that works.
Emotion is one of
the things, novelty
is one of the things that
converts short-term memory
to long-term memory.
Your second question
was about vision.
Vision is an extremely important
sense for human beings.
Not true for mice
and other animals.
And we have an amazing capacity.
You're right.
There have been
studies-- and I don't
want to give the wrong answer.
But you can look
through a magazine
that you've looked through
a couple of years ago
and identify every picture.
Yeah, I've seen that picture.
That's normal.
We have an amazing
capacity for visual memory.
That is because a third
of our cerebral cortex
is devoted to vision.
It is such an important
process for us.
I interviewed
somebody in the book
who was a blind person,
who's congenitally blind.
And she doesn't have
pigment in her retina.
And so there's no
question about it
being malingering or something.
We did put her in an
fMRI, and she can't see.
But a third of her cortex is
sitting there with nothing
to do.
So what happens is other
senses get wired to the cortex.
She can see pictures by putting
her fingers over a page,
and she's probably picking up
on little thermal differences.
We can do this,
maybe, if we practice.
I mean, we could all play the
violin I suppose, in theory.
But she's using
this enormous brain
power that has nothing to do,
normally devoted to vision.
She can echolocate
walking around.
She has tremendous synesthesia,
because her senses get mixed.
She can read five times
faster than anyone else--
than the sighted person.
And it just turns up the speed
until it sounds like gibberish,
and that's no problem
for her to decode it.
Because the brain
power is devoted to it.
So it's true, vision
is very important.
And people who do have
these remarkable abilities
from memory, one of the
tricks they always use
is to make an image.
It makes them concoct some
image of a monkey sitting
on a chair that reminds
them of something else.
They create this
big scene, and then
they just describe the scene.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I just
had a quick question.
So what advances in
imaging technology
are going to be needed to
really continue to progress
the study of glia cells?
DOUGLAS FIELDS: Yeah.
Well, I'm working
on some of my labs
that will allow me to look at
myelin structure in a living
mouse without any dyes or
genetic engineering using
new spectroscopy methods
adapted to imaging.
I think there's a lot
of development imaging.
The two photon and the
[INAUDIBLE] focal imaging
have been a great help.
Fiber optic cameras
Really, building cameras--
building microscopes
that are miniature microscopes
that can be put on the skull
and connected with a fiber
optic lens into the brain,
and then we can
see neurons firing.
So that's one area.
There's a lot of area-- because
optogenetics stimulates neurons
with light, being able to direct
laser beams so that you can not
just stimulate a
whole bunch of tissue,
but you can target individual
cells-- imagine that--
and begin to decode
this network.
Because you can activate
specific cells in any sequence,
and you can record the
responses with the camera
to all of these, this
whole population, things
you could never do with
the electrode-- not never.
Never say never-- but very
hard to do with electrodes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: OK, I wish we
could have more time.
But we're going to wrap up.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
And thanks to Dr.
Douglas Fields.
This was really fascinating.
DOUGLAS FIELDS:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]